[Música]
habitualmente vivimos en una burbuja
quienes tenemos la suerte de disfrutar
de una vida buena y cómoda de contar con
un soporte familiar sentirnos queridas
tener un hogar salud trabajo amistades
aficiones crecemos y vivimos con una
sensación de seguridad básica de
invulnerabilidad
nos sentimos protegidas en nuestro mundo
las desgracias y le suceden a otros los
ecos de sucesos que escuchamos en la
televisión en ocasiones nos conmueven
pero no nos impactan de forma duradera
flotamos en nuestra burbuja
desconectadas del dolor y el sufrimiento
del mundo incluso del que acontece en
nuestro entorno más próximo
en euskadi tenemos un ejemplo muy
cercano en las décadas de terrorismo que
padecimos es increíble cómo pudimos
sumergirnos en la burbuja de nuestra
vida cotidiana y desconectarnos del
entorno hostil que nos rodeaba cómo
llegamos a normalizar los avisos de
bomba la quema sistemática de
contenedores las calles llenas de
pintadas y carteles de apoyo a la lucha
armada la violencia que padecían tantas
personas a nuestro alrededor los
secuestros los asesinatos que se
producían al otro lado de la puerta en
la calle en el bar
yo también vivía en una burbuja y eso
que desde muy niña crecí con la
presencia cotidiana de la amenaza medita
no podía salir de casa sin escoltas
tenía que mirar debajo del coche antes
de subir recuerdo su foto rodeada por
una diana en los carteles de la cuchi en
los que se señalaba a los enemigos del
pueblo
su nombre entre los papeles incautados
al comando araba pues a entzun pim pam
pum
la incertidumbre la inquietud y la
sombra de la amenaza me rondaban pero yo
las descartaba no dejaba que invadieran
mi núcleo de seguridad la certeza
interior de que mi familia y yo
estábamos a salvo de que no iba a
suceder no es nada malo
mi burbuja explotó de pronto el 22 de
febrero del año 2000 cuando asesinó a mi
padre
recuerdo aquel día con ese halo de
irrealidad que caracteriza las vivencias
intensas abrumadoras que nos arrollan
sin darnos margen para asimilar
en mi memoria guardo fragmentos de
imágenes sonidos sensaciones como una
película proyectada a cámara lenta
recuerdo sus últimas palabras antes de
salir de casa hace frío hoy o yo tengo
frío el estruendo la columna de humo un
grito en la calle una bomba correr con
mi amá escaleras abajo las sirenas el
corazón en la boca
mi hermano dónde está la furgoneta de la
ertzaintza nos llevan a casa entrar en
el salón y ver la vela con la que hay
está sabiendo el puro apenas diez
minutos antes todavía encendida y pensar
cómo te puede cambiar la vida en un
segundo
fue como si el suelo se convirtiera en
arenas movedizas como si me arrancaron
de cuajo un brazo o una pierna y tuviera
que aprender a andar atrás pies
sentimientos de fragilidad angustia
rabia miedo me invadieron con fuerza el
dolor y la tristeza la inmensa tristeza
lo inundaba todo y costaba respirar
recuerdo de aquellos primeros días la
sensación de querer hacerme un ovillo
cerrar los ojos y quedarme muy quieta a
zapa de mi dolor el temor a salir al
mundo exterior donde la vida sería para
los demás pero la mía se había detenido
me había sucedido algo terrible y me
sentía marcada para siempre tenía mucho
miedo de enfrentarme a la gente de
mirarles a los ojos y de lo que pudiera
haber reflejado en ellos el rechazo
incomodidad horror lástima
sin embargo me encontré con muchas
miradas cercanas cálidas tristes y
serenas que conectaban con mi sentir mi
insuflaban fortaleza y me arropaban
fueron muchos los gestos que nos
transmitieron que no estábamos solos han
pasado 21 años y todavía se me pone la
piel de gallina al recordarlos
las flores las velas encendidas dibujos
no estás en el lugar del atentado los
telegramas y cartas algunas de personas
desconocidas que nos trasladaban su
solidaridad el impulso de cercanía de
quienes se acercaron a la capilla
ardiente- el agur jauna toda la gente
que salió a la calle y aplaudía nuestro
paso camino del funeral
aquellos gestos que salían del corazón
impulsaban a tantas personas hacer algo
por aliviar nuestro dolor nos
conmovieron profundamente qué importante
es para cualquier víctima sentir el
calor del abrazo espontáneo el gesto
sencillo que indican estoy aquí no estás
sola tu dolor es mi dolor estoy contigo
así fue como descubrí la fuerza de la
compasión mi experiencia ha sido muy
dura y al mismo tiempo muy reveladora
pues despertó en mí una sensibilidad
especial descubrí mi fragilidad y
también comprendí la vulnerabilidad que
todas las personas compartimos dentro de
nuestra como una humanidad
ayer me ocurrió a mí lo que a ti te
sucede hoy me puede suceder a mí mañana
lo que a ellos les pasa nos puede pasar
a nosotros también estamos conectadas
relacionadas las unas con las otras
desde entonces soy capaz de ver y
comprender el sufrimiento gracias a esa
nueva mirada he aprendido a juzgar menos
a la ligera a pensar mucho menos en
términos de blanco y negro a ser más
humana y solidaria a rebelarse contra
las injusticias ser contundente contra
la violencia y comprometerme por un
mundo mejor
también he aprendido a relativizar ya
valorar lo que realmente es importante
en la vida
sabéis una de las cosas con las que más
me costó lidiar fue la sensación de
vacío y de falta de sentido con 20 años
me cayó de golpe aquella losa encima y
de pronto mi vida mis preocupaciones
anteriores y las de las personas de mi
edad quedaban tan lejos
sobreviví aferrándome a mis rutinas
retomen salida a las clases me refugio
en el estudio estaba con mi novio volví
a salir con mis amigas pronto recupere
la normalidad de la vida cotidiana pero
era una normalidad aparente hacia afuera
porque por dentro sentía un vacío
insondable
esa sensación me acompañó durante mucho
tiempo y todavía hoy me atenas a veces
ese vacío podría haberse llenado
fácilmente de odio y de rencor pero
afortunadamente en nuestra familia nos
apoyamos y nos hicimos fuertes en torno
al amor que compartimos ese amor fue el
motor que me impulsó para volver a mirar
al futuro con ilusión y esperanza
me dio la seguridad y la fuerza para
sostenernos frente a la adversidad de
afrontar los momentos más difíciles de
mi vida
me ayudó a agradecer y valorar todo lo
que tengo apreciar la sencillez de las
pequeñas cosas y sentir que a pesar de
lo que nos había sucedido la vida valía
la pena vivirla
me permitió asumir mi vulnerabilidad y
moverme confiada en el mundo mantener un
corazón limpio y transformar mi dolor en
algo constructivo
gracias a ello comprendí que los
vínculos de amor el cariño y los afectos
que compartimos con otras personas son
los que dan sentido a nuestras vidas nos
sostienen en los momentos de
incertidumbre nos conectan nos permiten
sentir nuestra vida enraizada y
entretejida con otras vidas sentir que
somos personas y pertenecemos a otras
personas
con los años he descubierto además que
el amor es un estado mental que se puede
cultivar y también un lugar un espacio
que habitar desde el que podemos elegir
relacionarnos con nosotros mismos con
los demás y con el mundo
todo el amor que recibimos a lo largo de
nuestras vidas y el que compartimos vive
en nosotros es la energía vital más pura
y luminosa una energía que se
retroalimenta el amor que sale de
nosotros vuelve a nosotros multiplicado
y que a medida que se cultiva tiende a
expandirse desde nosotros hacia nuestros
seres queridos hacia las personas con
las que nos relacionamos en nuestro día
a día hacia personas desconocidas
incluso hacia quienes no nos gustan
hacia toda la humanidad
de esta forma ensanchamos el alma y
desarrollamos una mirada solidaria que
nos permite comprender que al igual que
nosotros todas las personas buscan la
felicidad en su vida y junto con esta
comprensión nuestra propiedad de
felicidad cambia dejamos de mirarnos el
ombligo de pensar únicamente nuestro
bienestar personal y empezamos a
preocuparnos por la felicidad y el
bienestar de todas las personas
el amor y la compasión el deseo de que
todas las personas puedan tener opciones
de felicidad y el deseo de que todas las
personas estén libres del sufrimiento o
encuentren alivio al mismo son dos caras
de la misma moneda nos conectan con la
mejor versión de nosotras mismas son
anclas frente a la incertidumbre y
fuerzas de superación y crecimiento
personal y colectivo y es que allí donde
emerge nuestro lado más humano se
encuentra la mayor fuerza de
transformación social
mi burbuja explotó de pronto y me di de
bruces contra el suelo pero descubrí un
nuevo espacio que habitar un sitio que
no siempre es cómodo en el que a menudo
me siento vulnerable pero viva y
profundamente humana el lugar en el que
quiero estar mi lugar
y vosotras
queréis cultivar el amor y la compasión
y dejar esa huella en este mundo
el amor y la compasión no surgen de
forma instintiva hacia nuestros seres
queridos hacia las personas más cercanas
que sentimos que forman parte de nuestro
círculo de pertenencia la cuestión es
cómo de estrecho o de ancho dibujamos
ese círculo reflexiona sobre ello cómo
actúa es con vuestros seres queridos y
con personas menos próximas con las que
soléis coincidir
con personas que no conocéis
con personas que nos gustan o que sentís
distintas a vosotras
os invito a prestar una atención
consciente en vuestro día a día a todas
esas personas que están a vuestro
alrededor y habitualmente no veis
personas de las que estéis desconectadas
al hacerlo pensad para vosotros mismos
esta persona es un ser humano tan
complejo como yo
esta persona tiene una vida que va mucho
más allá de lo que yo conozco de ella es
importante para alguien y tiene seres
queridos por los que se preocupan
tal como yo esta persona tiene sus
debilidades y fortalezas sabe lo que es
estar triste tener miedo y conoce
también la alegría
al igual que yo esta persona desea ser
feliz y evitar el sufrimiento
imaginad cómo es cómo se siente ser esa
persona
experimentar con vuestro círculo de amor
y compasión probad a expandir lo seguro
que alguna vez habéis tirado una piedra
en un estanque la piedra al contacto con
el agua genera unas ondas que se
propagan en todas las direcciones en
forma de círculos concéntricos imaginad
que sois como esa piedra atreve usas
sumergidos a cultivar el amor y la
compasión y dejad que las ondas fluyan a
vuestro alrededor
[Aplausos]